قبل ستين عامًا ، كانت دبي مجتمعًا صغيرًا
لصيد الأسماك والغوص بحثًا عن اللؤلؤ ،
وهي اليوم موطن لحوالي ثلاثة ملايين
مقيم ولديها 16 مليون
زائر دولي سنويًا ، فكيف
حدث هذا جيدًا ، كان لهذا الأمر
علاقة كبيرة به.
لقد مر أكثر من مليار مسافر عبر بوابات مطار الركاب ، ولكن عندما
تم افتتاحه في عام 1960 ، كان به عدد قليل من
المباني الصغيرة ومدرج واحد مصنوع
من الرمال المضغوطة ليأتي من العدم
ليكون في موقع مثل
أكبر مطار دولي في العالم.
هذا هو جون غرانت ، وهو
محلل كبير في شركة أو إيه جي ، أحد موردي بيانات الطيران الرائدين في العالم ،
وأعتقد أن التفرد في دبي
هو أنها ليست مطارًا بل هي جزء من
إستراتيجية الدولة وهي جزء من
برنامج استخدموا فيه الهواء
تطوير الخدمات كمحفز
للنمو الاقتصادي للسياحة ، الخدمات المالية ،
كل شيء أمر ببناء المطار في
عام 1959 من قبل
الحاكم آنذاك  كان شاكيرا سعيد آل مكتوم ،
لقد كان مجالًا جويًا صحراويًا في
مكان مناسب استراتيجيًا
للطائرات التي تطير بين أستراليا
وأوروبا وتحتاج إلى التوقف والتزود بالوقود ،
فإن النجاح النهائي لدبي يتعلق
بالمكان الذي يقع فيه الشرق الأوسط
في منتصف السفر حول العالم
يقول الخبراء إن حوالي ثلث سكان العالم
يعيشون في رحلة طيران مدتها أربع ساعات من
دبي ويمكن الوصول إلى ثلثيهم في
غضون ثماني ساعات من حيث بدأت الرحلة ،
لكنها كانت
بداية فكرة نتحدث عنها
مطار نما ونما للتو
ونما شيئًا واحدًا ساعد على هذا
النمو هو اكتشاف النفط في عام 1966 ، فقد
غذى الاستثمار على نطاق واسع في
البنية التحتية لشركة Bhai ولم يكن المطار
استثناءً بحلول السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
كان لدى مطار دبي الدولي مبنى جديد
مبنى برج مراقبة جديد وكان لديه
مدرج إسفلتي جديد يمكن أن
يستوعب معظم الطائرات تسوق جودي المجاني
ثم تبعه مدرج ثانٍ
وكانت شركة طيران الإمارات الخاصة بدبي عام 1985
مفعّلة  د على مدى العقود التالية
، ارتفعت أعداد الركاب بمساعدة محطة جديدة وبوابة جديدة ،
وكان هناك إدراك بأن النفط سينفد
في مرحلة ما وسيحتاج إلى
استبداله بشيء كانت دبي لا تزال
تُنظر إليه على أنها وجهة في الصحراء
لم يكن هناك منتج سياحي.  لم يكن
هناك ما يمكن إيقافه لذلك كان على طيران الإمارات
والحكومة العمل على إنشاء
حزم توقف لبناء فنادق خمس نجوم
على الرغم من التحديات على مر السنين
من الحوادث الدولية إلى
تأثير الأزمة المالية العالمية في عام
2008 استمرت أعداد ركاب DX B
في النمو.  - ساعد الاستيلاء على
محطة جديدة وشركة طيران وطنية ثانية
على مواكبة الطلب المتزايد
، وبينما لا تزال الخطط جارية لمطار
آل مكتوم الدولي القريب
لتجاوزه يومًا ما في الحجم ،
سيُعرف مطار دبي الدولي دائمًا بأنه
جزء حيوي من نجاح طيران الإمارات